thanks sir thank you everybody I'm Nick
Gillespie and we here with Matt Welch
and what we're going to talk about today
we are just in case anybody has
forgotten or hasn't bought a bunch of
hardcover copies for next Christmas yet
we are the co-authors of the Declaration
of Independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America which
will be coming out in paperback with a
new forward but that will be coming out
in May or June which is a good good news
to get the word out about the
libertarian alternative to the status
quo why Democrat versus Republican is
the wrong way to view the 2012 election
and you know I guess we ask this when we
talk in front of people and reason
people we know a bit better but how many
people here are registered Democrats
okay there's a couple you're including
john stossel aye manya i already showed
johnson well he's a registered communist
actual is that but now but and how many
are registered Republicans okay if you
know a few more and how many of you are
either independent or registered
independent okay well this is you know
it seems like a very okay libertarian
will ask who's a registered little
paranoid I was going to say this is a
very lackluster crowded because I think
only about thirty percent of hands went
up but you know we are trained from you
know in utero now i'm pretty sure to
think about politics in terms of
democrat and republican for good reason
i mean these are the two major parties
and you know we know that the next
president god help us all is going to be
either a Democrat or a Republican but
this is not the in the end or
increasingly it is becoming less and
less important what the party labels are
and more what the policies are and at
the same time that the labels are
becoming less important unfortunately
many of the policies that are being
pursued by the Democrats and Republicans
are become
more and more similar so what we're
going to do today is talk about why
democrat republican and this is not
enough pie in the sky type of thing
we're not hoping for a third party
that's going to be called you know the
ron paul party as good as he's been and
the injection of true alternative ideas
into Main Street political discourse or
that the Libertarian Party is going to
take over but we need to start thinking
about politics and ways other than
Democratic and Republican Matt you want
to hi everyone and thank you all for
reading the book those of you who did
and talking to us about it it's been
very interesting the reaction from
various people kind of surprise to us I
think as well we just finished the the
forwards on your thumb drive we for the
paperback edition and we had to resist
the temptation of just writing a we told
you so over and over again every poll
that has basically come out since the
time we turned in the original
manuscript has just gone further in the
direction of people disaffiliated from
the two political parties USA Today had
a piece out in December in the Obama era
I think was the timeline basically 2.5
million people have dropped the
registration or there's 2.5 million
fewer registered voters in the
Democratic Republican Party's think of
this could there possibly be a more
fortuitous set up for the Republican
Party than the last three years of Obama
and and what the economy has done and
yet in that time Republicans have lost
eight hundred thousand registered voters
it's a it's incredibly you have to work
it's like we rich dennis is here so i
want to make a lot of bad white sox
references but you have to work as hard
as dick allen to squander your talent or
advantage as much as he did Gallup has
been measuring this they measured every
month basically and then in January of
every year they come out with here's the
number of self-identified Republicans
Democrats and independents they came out
with the new one this January mesh
I love 2011 I think the vinyl number now
is forty percent independence they said
it's the largest moment for independence
in at least six decades those trends as
our book shows it's basically doubled
since 1970 its accelerated in the recent
years there's reason to believe that in
an election year people will kind of
crawl back into and listen to the dog
whistle of to party politics but it's
clear that this is where the long-term
trends are going and it's fascinating
and it's making politics more
interesting and more possible if you
look not yet not yet the early the first
primary a season for the Republican
Party getting back to their squandered
advantage voter turnout is flat too low
you would think that the Republican
Party would be motivated to vote against
Barack Obama and it's actually much
worse than flat or low turnout if you
look at people who self-identify as
Republicans they accounted for something
like eighty six eighty eight percent of
people who participate in GOP primaries
in 2008 now it's like 75 percent the
only reason that their numbers are
respectable is that independents are
flooding into the system and those
independents are voting for Ron Paul
this is by numbers of like forty percent
close to fifty percent in some of the
early primary States this is producing a
fascinating conundrum for the Republican
Party right now because basically the
only thing with juice in the party of
young voters people under 29 have gone
for Ron Paul not so much a Florida pin
them in the other states close to fifty
percent so this is the only future that
the party has and the party hates at
least half of what that future is
telling them and so you have you have
people like Bill Kristol saying we need
to kick out Ron Paul and the movement
surrounding them it's discreet is
reputable and then you have other people
like Jim DeMint who will talk about
later who is saying this is the most
important new block of voters we have to
figure out what to do with them what
this is also creating is unprecedented
volatility
no how many of you follow the website
fivethirtyeight.com nate silver's
politics number-crunching at the new
york times it's very good I commend it
particularly for every two or three days
he writes something along the lines of
lots of charts and things saying okay
this one's unprecedented you know we are
in a situation we've never seen before
the vote swing in Florida went something
like 30 percentage points in about five
days between Gingrich and Romney no one
is seen that before every Republican
nominee who won South Carolina has won
the presidential nomination well that's
probably not going to happen so each new
day because of these independents who
are coming in and acting like swing
voters and because people who are even
registered Republicans to think like
Republicans are acting more like
independent minded people that's
creating volatility volatility isn't
necessarily good but it's an indication
that things can change a lot faster than
than you supposed here is I had to write
it down the list of people who according
to different polls have been at various
times frontrunner in the GOP
presidential primary whether they
actually were in the race or not Sarah
Palin Herman Cain Newt Gingrich Mike
Huckabee Rick Perry Michele Bachmann and
Donald Trump at least I think Tim t pas
never really got off the ground but i
think it's basically everybody but ron
paul so far has been a front-runner at
some point speaks to this volatility
there's a if you look at the division
between tea party-affiliated republicans
and non tea party-affiliated republicans
the non tea party people flirted with a
lot of various candidates but basically
since last fall have gone for Romney and
if you see a char which we don't have of
where the museum has been among tea
party-affiliated Republic the chart
looks like someone's having a heart
attack that's an EKG it's it's someone
new every day which again speaks to
something good that's happening but also
speaks to something back which is to say
can
you believe that after three years of
hysterical not hysterical but strong
public reaction to bail out economics we
had the creation of a tea party from
nothing where scott brown won Teddy
Kennedy's old seed where every single
the California special election in May
2009 totally repudiated that sick
political classes ideas of reform every
single signal in the market for three
years has been in one direction and that
has been for limiting restraining
government reacting negatively to
Obamacare after all of this the
Republican Party is on the verge of
nominating the person who created the
individual mandate who every single day
on the campaign trail attacks Obama for
cutting Medicare let it sink in who says
that we've gutted the military to
unprecedented levels I have no idea what
the hell he's talking about so we have a
guy who is not talking at all about
cutting the size and scope of government
who's looking like he's going to be the
nominee so which is fascinating it
speaks to that the modern republican
party after its own a collusion in
misgovernance for a long time hasn't
figured out what it's going to be you
know the classic was that was supposed
to be a three-legged stool of fiscal
conservatives social conservatives and
defense Hawks kind of unclear you know
where does Gingrich Newt Gingrich fit on
that we don't really know so I care rich
has been advised by both his doctor and
furniture makers not to sit on stools I
hear from a lot of free market people in
Washington focusing on what to do this
year about how to think about the
election people were more Republican
than I am which isn't hard to do or hard
to be that they're not focused on the
presidency that the thing to do this
year is to think about the United States
Senate you need more Rand Paul's you
need more Pat Toomey's you need more
Mike Leigh's coming in and you need to
ultimately win arguments more than when
presidential elections I mean just
looking at the the field of Republicans
Gingrich is going around
that this is the most important election
in in all of our lifetimes they say that
every time it's always not true and I
don't think this one is any more true
than another than than other ones but in
you know we had a non Obama president
recently his name is George W Bush it
wasn't all puppy dogs and rainbows back
then then either so the point i think in
getting involved with politics and
thinking about it and how to use
independence is to create more people
who are talking proactively about
freedom and about limiting you know
averting the fiscal calamity that's
going on I don't know how many of you
watch mitch Daniels the response to the
state of the union address the other a
day or the other week it was this weird
moment of ha here's a guy actually
talking about the problem that we face
in a way that I haven't seen in a
Republican debate and i watch all those
damn things I haven't really seen out on
the stump very much so it speaks to we
don't really know where Republicans
heads are at right now we need to create
more incentives for mitch Daniels type
of approach going forward and with that
I'll hand it over yeah it's so you know
being Republican is not enough to
counter Obama and I guess you know to
bring back if Democrat versus Republican
is wrong is the wrong way to understand
things being a Republican is not enough
because the Republicans are not the
mainstream I don't want to say the
mainstream candidates the the likely the
presumptive nominee make Mitt Romney is
not offering an alternative to Obama in
a lot of ways he was Obama before Obama
was born this is a screen capture from
fox news channel not fox business by the
way i want to point out which is the
greatest channel on all of TV and all of
history and i do mean that actually but
on fox news this was a while ago you
know and fox news is pretty much in the
tank for Mitt Romney or for the
Republicans and even they have trouble
identifying
Obama and Mitt Romney if you notice
there they actually slotted in a picture
of Obama so that this is kind of where
we are and this is where Republican and
Democrat doesn't get at it because the
Republicans with the exception of Ron
Paul and then you know Gary Johnson who
split off and is now making I what I
think it's going to be an interesting
and useful run as a libertarian
candidate nobody's talking about
spending which is the real issue it
encapsulates all the other issues that
are at stake here including Obamacare
including military spending including
whatnot this is the Congressional Budget
Office just recently released its
updated scenario it's going forward they
released to basically and they one is
the baseline projection where they
actually take politicians at their words
and they say okay you know what when the
when politicians are when lawmakers say
we're going to cut this and that you
know a couple years down the road we've
never cut it in the past but we're going
to do it now they put it in and that's
the baseline projection and this is so
if you listen to politicians you know
going forward from 2011 we have a
baseline projection where magically
spending goes down and then even
politicians can't lie enough where
they're like oh you know in 2022 that
we're going to start spending more again
the alternative fiscal scenario is the
one to look at because that's generally
considered the realistic scenario so the
baseline projection says things you know
it takes politicians at their words that
they're going to actually cut the
reimbursement of Medicare to doctors
which by law they have been supposed to
be doing now for over a decade and have
never done that they're not going to
patch the alternative minimum tax so
they'll actually collect a lot more in
revenue even though they've changed you
know they make an AMT patch every time
they have to so the alternative fiscal
scenario is actually the more likely
outcome and even that is a rosy scenario
but this is the question the spending
when is the last time that you heard
Mitt Romney
Newt Gingrich talk about actual spending
cuts that they're going to make
year-over-year spending cuts anyone the
you know Newt Gingrich is focused on a
moon colony which is good I mean and he
doesn't even pretend that he's going to
take that from starving children or ship
you know grammar school kids to be the
janitors and the miners on the moon or
anything he's like no we'll just layer
that on top because it's really cool and
I support a moon colony I support Newt
Gingrich being you know the first
colonists on the moon but it should be
done with private dollars and maybe he
can swap his Tiffany line of credit you
know as seed money for getting at least
to the outer reaches of Earth's
gravitational field but and Mitt Romney
does not talk about cutting anything as
matt said he is running you know as the
man who invented the programmer signed
off on the program that became Obamacare
he is he runs around saying that I'm
going to protect Medicare which is not
simply an alternative Medicare is part
of the problem and this is part of the
problem with repealing Obamacare which
can be done and which hopefully will be
done immediately or won't even go into
practice depending on a couple of
Supreme Court ruling so we could talk
about that later but Medicare is the
problem because it let's pretend that
Obamacare never happened that it was
voted down and it was never popular
among the general population and
interestingly as well as it gets closer
to being put into place it's less
popular with people and as we actually
as you know we all remember Nancy Pelosi
saying we've got to pass this bill so we
can find out what's in it as the details
are dribbling out it's like you know
it's a trying to think it's like another
Pokemon movie or something you like when
you hear more and more details of the
plot you don't want to go see this movie
even if you're Herman Cain which is
awesome by the way whoever if you're a
Republican I know there are a couple
hands up consider that you are part of a
party where the / you know for a while
the leader in
the GOP primary race was Herman Cain was
quoting lines of dialogue from the
Pokemon movie that is pretty stunning
I'd but in any case the real issue is
spending and yet the New York Times had
an article that was pretty interesting
talking to a bunch of GOP operatives
their big plan their big play going now
until the election is to talk about the
Keystone pipeline and Obama's refusal to
okay that which is a really I mean it's
a good issue and it's a solid issue it's
something that should have been built at
you know there were actually a lot of
Democrats who were in favor of doing
that and whatnot it's a sign of how
idiotic and it awful Obama is as a
president across the board I mean
there's really nothing good to say about
Obama but if you are a Republican and
you're supposed to be an alternative to
Obama and you're not talking about
spending which went up under your own
party and then really went up under
Obama and debt taxes the implications
for taxes for credit ratings and all of
that type of stuff and you're talking
about the Keystone pipeline you're not
talking about what is really important
and also what's going to turn the
economy around so this is one of the
reasons why Democrat versus Republican
doesn't matter if Mitt Romney's not
talking about spending as the issue and
as the main issue which takes precedent
over everything he's pretty useless and
you know he's going to be useless when
he gets into power and one way of also
thinking about that is that if he's not
going to talk about that now when he's
not in power in this climate when's he
going to bring it up yeah and the
Republicans I mean this is I as a lot of
you know I split time between Ohio
southwestern Ohio and DC John Boehner
the Speaker of the House is my
congressman just a couple of weeks
before the 2010 election he released a
plan that was going to be the Republican
roadmap to cutting government and in
that program he didn't cut anything he's
like you know what we're going to zero
out a hundred percent of things that
don't include Medicare Social Security
defense spending and a bunch of other
pet projects I mean he laid out a
scenario by which he was going to be
draconian on
actually about two percent of the budget
and even that he wasn't going to cut it
completely so we know that these are not
the people that we're gonna you know you
you don't want them in a bar fight you
don't want the mentor back in a bar
fight and you don't want them with a
majority with a clear majority
government but the other real issues and
these are ones that show the power of
moving beyond the Democratic and
Republican labels and this is you know
our book is premise upon the idea that
independence are growing in number and
that they're growing in number for
rational reasons that everywhere else in
our lives we're getting more
individualized treatment we're getting
more personalized understanding and
we're deep bundling and de-linking
things so that you know you don't when
you when you go increasingly you Kodak
you know it's just filed for bankruptcy
is about to again one of our controlling
metaphors is Kodak used to force you to
develop 12 pictures or 24 pictures or 48
pictures to get the one or two that you
wanted technology and other things
routed around that so we know we don't
have to do that anymore and Kodak
treated us like captives who would
always have to go to a fotomat booth who
would always have to use their film and
they're gone now because they didn't
adapt and they didn't realize that the
you know power and longevity comes from
enabling individuals to do what they
want to do and to create their own
worlds not forcing them to take a bundle
of options that don't have anything to
do with one another and that the
Republican and Democratic parties have
been doing this all along the Republican
Party say hey if you want to trim the
top marginal tax rate you know by a
quarter of a percent come on you're on
our team and by the way you also have to
sign on to wars with that end you have
to sign out to the drug war etc
Democrats might say if you want you know
if you want to
have access to abortion or to
reproductive choice you've also got to
sign on to super high tax rates as if
these two things are inextricably linked
as opposed to a bundle of options that
everywhere else in our lives we're
starting to say to the people we buy
things from or do business with now just
give me what I want don't load me up
with a bunch of other stuff so that's
why independents are growing in
independence are increasingly
nonpartisan their disaffiliated with the
republicans and democrats and this is
showing up in some freedom issues that
have been in the news Lee how many of
you followed the protests against the
Stop Online Privacy Act okay or piracy
act sopa and it's a house version pippa
this is a fascinating thing where you
had Democrats and Republicans pushing
this bill there was a broad consensus
and then you had all sorts of people
including you know Google and Wikipedia
and whatnot creating a true push back
that was not partisan in nature I chris
dodd the former senator from Congress
are from connecticut is now the head of
the motion picture association of
america was one of the major lobbyists
for this bill because it helps move or
they think it helps movie companies and
big content providers but he went to
republicans and democrats and bought
their votes to push this which would
have given the government unprecedented
control over basically certifying or d
certifying websites in ways that were
perhaps not as Apocalyptica some of the
critics of the bill thought but it was
it need it certainly needs more time and
it was a bad law people rose up against
that and shut that down for the time
being it'll keep coming back it will
keep coming back but this was
fascinating to see a broad-based tea
party style revolt by the people most
affected by piece of legislation you
know and that's these are the issues
that are being increasingly addressed in
nonpartisan ways drug legalization
initiative
rob Campea who David pointed out last
night from the Marijuana Policy Project
is here there are drug legalization
initiatives around the state in places
like california washington state
colorado that are polling extremely well
and they are made up not of traditional
democrats and republicans but by
broad-based coalition's that are really
shredding the envelope in terms of
taking giant steps forward towards
liberating people from really bad stupid
laws increasingly state level changes
are also somewhat following suit Indiana
had a view an interesting right to work
initiative that got passed largely
Republican doing with mitch Daniels
who's leaving office soon so he he feels
that he's bulletproof in a way that
people like John Kasich and Scott Walker
in Ohio and Wisconsin might not be
that's that is you know that it's good
they actually had a bunch of Democratic
co-sponsors for that type of sub 2
because enough people there are starting
to realize that if you're in the
industrial Midwest you know getting
being you know having one hundred
percent union representation of 0% jobs
doesn't really even you know if you're a
union boss you're not even making it
money off of that anymore but then in
states like New York andrew Cuomo has
actually in various ways made cause with
certain Republicans to push back on
public on public employee unions it's
it's tricky and he's already
unfortunately starting to kind of
present a lot of ugly family traits and
he's backsliding uncertain of his
answers but we're starting to see at the
state level these kind of trans partisan
or coalition's that are growing that are
not strictly partisan anymore California
is an interesting test case not simply
because it's so huge as an economy and
as a disaster but because the
Republicans are so small there what what
is happening though is that we
there are pockets of Democrats there who
realize that Jerry Brown who most
recently was talking up the high-speed
rail initiative which is wildly
unpopular he was talking about it as you
know that it's a latter-day version of
the great pyramids and key opps which
let you know wonders you know whether or
not he should be the first person buried
in the high-speed rail system or not and
now Matt is actually going to talk a bit
about you know and this is pulling off
of another main theme of our book of how
when you start getting beyond the
partisan labels what what is the
political power and the power for social
change that comes from political
independence it's we talk about in the
book about using independence as a
weapon and it's interesting to see how
that was used in November of 2010 you'll
recall the house became Republican again
there's a new sort of tea party
generation and the comments from some of
the pre-existing Republicans on Capitol
Hill in that first week were fascinating
I there was a Matt kibbe can tell the
story freedom works better than I can
I'm sure but basically John Boehner and
Mitch McConnell said okay kids all that
earmark stuff it's a good way to win
election but we got to do the adults got
to do business here go go go put on your
big boy pants and they turned the other
way on earmarks and the Tea Party right
which had just elected them said no you
can't do that they changed John Boehner
zh behavior I think he probably still
cried but he had to actually pass your
mark reform because of that jim DeMint
who sort of leader or an a leader of the
Tea Party caucus in the Senate in those
first days made a comment of you can't
be a fiscal conservative and not be a
social conservative there are these
shots going across the bow there is a
piece in think the wall street journal
by Arthur Brooks ahead of
American Enterprise Institute I think
I'd folder from heritage and somebody
else who might as well have been John
McCain which is calm John McCain bill
kristol yes okay so yeah John McCain who
which is basically welcome to Washington
tea party don't touch defense at all so
all these things were happening now look
at what Jim DeMint is saying Jim DeMint
who endorsed Mitt Romney in the 2008
cycle he didn't endorse anybody this
time around and he spent a lot of time
talking about the virtues of Ron Paul
saying to the Republican Party we have
to listen to him we might disagree with
him about a couple of things but this is
where all of the future of the party is
coming we need to and as the quote here
for those of you can't read type one of
the things that's hurt the so-called
conservative alternative is saying
negative things about Ron Paul I'd like
to see a Republican Party that embraces
a lot of the libertarian ideas de mids
flip in a bit he came to our office on
Tuesday of this week he's got a new book
out called now or never I think and
that's basically talking about the
fiscal catastrophe that we face in in a
very kind of direct way and so he was
hype in the book but he was spending a
lot of the time basically saying in
reaching out to libertarians via us and
and that that it has to be the future of
the Republican Party um and he kept
putting it that once I know that you are
serious about cutting government as
serious as I am then we can have some
other conversations in fact we had some
of those other conversations after the
camera stopped rolling where to our
shock he was saying things like yeah so
we can start having conversations about
things like the drug war about that this
is from Jim DeMint who's been the drug
warriors or as far as i know for his
whole career and about closing down a
lot of our bases abroad and and
realizing that military spending is not
the same as defense spending though and
you know he was he was championing the
way that Ron Paul is articulating
defense issues that is a sea change in
gym demands behavior and part of it
comes I mean maybe it's an intellectual
rash
tioning or maybe he's just figuring out
that like every party in opposition at
the moment libertarianism looks awful
good for for a week and a half but it's
I think using independence as a weapon
against the likes of him is is changing
that kind of behavior looking forward we
can only hope we haven't quite seen it
yet that that the especially civil
libertarian left the anti-war left will
begin and the anti drug war left will
begin seeing this as a tactic we saw in
Occupy Wall Street which has kind of
crashed and burned deservedly so in many
ways but you saw people thinking through
how can we use the tactics of the tea
party including the tactics of
independent to change behavior I don't
think Occupy Wall Street will change any
helpful behavior but we would hopefully
we'll see some of that chipping away at
things like the drug war in places like
Washington and Colorado I think it's
fair to say in this very volatile moment
when things can swing so much that the
next major breakthrough for freedom or
in this direction is probably going to
come from people who are using
independence as a tactic and as a and as
a personal lifestyle okay great thanks
guys
you